foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
is Chris Collinsworth set to join us
there he is done oh okay here's the
official uh introduction Chris
Collinsworth NBC Sports joining Mike
Tirico they got the Cowboys and the
Eagles this weekend Sunday Night
Football on NBC and peacock Chris thanks
for joining us here what's the dumbest
locker room fight you were ever involved
in with the Bengals
wow this is a perfect question because
it is really insightful
we were at the Super Bowl in 1981 season
82 we're playing the 49ers
we got stuck in the presidential
motorcade going to the game in Pontiac
there's only one Road in and there's one
road out and the president had that road
and everything else on that road was
dead stopped so here are our team buses
with this police motorcade trying to get
to the stadium and we're just sitting
there like it's a parking lot we finally
get to the stadium now usually you're
there three and a half hours beforehand
you got to get taped you got to get you
know dress and pre-game warm-ups an hour
before right at this whole thing
we got to the stadium for the Super Bowl
about
an hour and 45 minutes before kickoff
and people are losing their minds and
there was a knock down drag out fight
between two of my teammates over who was
gonna get taped first the table went
flying over I was thinking this is
either going to be the greatest start to
a Super Bowl and I'm gonna have this I'm
going to tell this story on every single
show that I'm on for the rest of my life
or this is gonna be we're gonna go out
and be down 20 to nothing in the first
half we were down 20 to nothing in the
first half that's exactly what happened
have you ever told that story before
I've told it over a few drinks here and
there you know but did the Niners get
caught in traffic
they don't know they were probably in
the presidential motorcade they had all
the superstars over there no Montana and
you know those guys they've been lost
they knew everybody
all right couple things if you're the
Eagles are you preparing for Dak
Prescott Sunday night
I don't think so you know I it if he
shows up it'll be you know we've seen
the other of this we did uh Cooper
Rush's first game that he won in
Minnesota so we were there and the whole
thing was that going to play was he not
going to play went out for pregame
warm-up he didn't and then you know they
won and he's on a five-game win streak
now so I I would be surprised at this
point
um
to some extent because nobody likes to
kill a win streak anyway and that was my
question going into it is an 85 Dak
Prescott worth taking Cooper rush out of
the lineup and I would guess probably no
especially given how Dak got the job
right from Tony Romo and he was on an
eight-game heater where they had won all
those games in a row and then they
didn't take him out so I think if you
have a bonus week and you can get your
primary quarterback back 100 healthy and
a full week of practice I would imagine
the Cowboys do that we know that they
have a blueprint here and it's worked so
it's there's a little more of a sample
size with these five games they run the
football they play good defense now when
Dak comes back
what's the game plan and does it change
I think that's a really great question
because I don't know I mean this defense
may be that good right they may be that
good why do you watch them on Sunday
night right and I'll be I'll be working
this over pretty good uh they fly around
the ball they only play limited numbers
of snaps and they play a ton of
defensive linemen every single play
looks like the start of the four by 100
major you know relay it does and they
are just smoking around there when when
the other team breaks a run you'll see
The Far Side defensive end who has no
chance of getting there turning and
sprinting to the ball I mean sprinting
to the ball so they let them play as
long as they can Sprint everywhere on
the field at all times and when you've
got some of the the talent that they
have on that football team you know
obviously starting with Micah Parsons
and uh Lawrence and this kid doran's
Armstrong's been playing great for him
um they they've even got this rookie Sam
Williams who's really he played his best
game of the year uh the other night so
when you have that kind of talent and
they're unleashing the hounds now what
does that mean as far as playing the
Eagles though right because the Eagles
aren't going to do what Matthew Stafford
did which was sit back in the pocket and
take a beating I mean that's not who the
Eagles are so they're going to be doing
the rpos they're going to run a lot
um this might be one of those crazy NFL
games that both teams run 35 times in
this game so I it's it's you know don't
make a mistake don't mess it up uh we've
got a great running game and then who
can pop a couple of big plays in the
passing game probably decides talking to
Chris Collinsworth Sunday night it'll be
the showdown between the Eagles and the
Cowboys what do you need to see from
Jalen hurts
that maybe puts him in that category
where he's a MVP candidate or are you
already there
um I think you need to see him doing the
playoffs it's like all these guys you
know I mean Patrick Mahomes we saw do it
in the playoffs right I mean we've seen
um you know all the Josh Allen Joe Burns
yeah yeah all the guys that got their
team there
um and you know it's it's significant as
well because
this this Philadelphia Eagles team
across the board like when I was getting
ready for the season this year I just
put the two lineups next to each other
and you sort of went you know other than
Dak probably being better than Jalen at
this point in his career in preseason
then you know I think the Eagles have a
better roster so there is a certain
thing that says all right well how much
do we have to pay Jalen right and are
you going to go to 50 million you know I
I don't know are we going to 40 are we
going to you know where is it that we're
going because the next alternative is do
you try and go find another quarterback
in the draft and that that mindset I'm
starting to hear more and more and more
of around the league that you know if
you're going to play the read option
game and especially now with all the
concussion stuff uh coming to the fore
are you gonna have to have a couple of
those kind of guys if that's what you
want to play and you want to run your
quarterback
then you know there's there's just a lot
of really interesting Financial
considerations that go into having a guy
that's going to run you know and Josh
Allen so far has been able to survive
because he's so big Jalen's been
fantastic and he's been throwing it a
lot better and occasionally now you'll
see him sit in the pocket read one out
and make a throw so I think the growth
that he's making throwing the football
has been sort of incremental but has
been very much an uphill you know an
uphill climb that he's actually learning
to be the complete quarterback and then
at that point you go all right here's
your 50 million because he can do
everything else but I wonder why we
don't have a soft a softer landing spot
Chris for these quarterbacks because if
Mitchell trubisky said I'll take 25
million
for three years with the Bears is he
still there uh you know we get this next
guy up is going to get this amount of
money but you know if Baker Mayfield had
taken less and said look I'll give me 25
million but the ego gets involved with
the quarterback and the agent therefore
it's either you get this you get the bag
or you know you get the heave ho
yeah or you get Tom Brady and he works
for about 50 percent of what he's worth
right yeah so it does all come down to
that and
um I I think that that as a quarterback
it's really hard to recognize where you
fit because the game's evolving I mean
there's no question about it Lamar
Jackson was an MVP in this league if
Jalen keeps going who knows what he
could end up doing in this league I mean
they've got three receivers that can
really play and they've been putting up
numbers in the passing game
um so it it's it's possible that he gets
there but I think as as a fan base we
all want to see him do it on a stage
like this like this is he did it he
played in the playoffs last year got
beat by Brady they got behind they
couldn't throw the ball well enough to
go come make a comeback right now you're
gonna see him in a probably our highest
rated game of the year uh on Sunday
night and playing the arch rival Dallas
Cowboys and does he rise up and if they
get behind can he can he bring him from
behind I mean it's all the same stuff
that they're going to do with with any
quarterback that's breaking in Josh
Allen was the same way you know when he
first got to say oh he's not accurate
enough to complete all the passes and he
runs too much and then he's broken
through you know I think Lamar is broken
through and now we'll see whether or not
Jalen can
when's the last time you said something
and as soon as it left your mouth you
went uh oh
I'm going to get roughed up on social
media
about
I don't know four or five minutes ago
probably no no during a game during a
game how often do you go oh
Dan I swear to you almost every time
I've been in trouble
I didn't know it till the next day
you know because if you knew you were
going to be in trouble you wouldn't have
said it right I mean come on I mean as
much as you talk every single day yeah
right it just something comes out of
your mouth at some point and you go and
then somebody will say and and probably
the the ones that get me the most are my
kids you know my kids will have it ready
and waiting for me the minute that I
check my phone the next time like you
are you're trending and trending is
never a good thing trending I've learned
is you know the only time I was ever
trending that it was a good thing I
never I would have never in a million
years good or bad I I never know with
what I'm doing is good or bad but when
in Chicago when they did the double
doink off the the upright and and so I'm
sitting there and and you know and I was
like I can't believe the Bears lost on a
double doink and didn't think anything
about it not a thing
my son jack is in the booth and he's
right behind me he goes dad as soon as
the game's over dad dad you are trending
you're trending I was like oh no what
did I say I had no idea he goes no no no
this time it's a good thing they like
double door
I know I'm trending and it's a good
thing I've never been in this space
before this is fantastic yeah so no it's
it's awful I mean you know I I I don't
even want to recount all the ones
because I'm hoping people forgot what I
did what was that I did I'll leave you
with this uh give me the one thing that
concerns you about the Chiefs the one
thing that concerns you about the bills
since those two teams meet this weekend
um the bills are a little thinner in the
secondary than I would have liked to
have seen when Trey white comes back
we'll see you know Micah Hyde that's
those that that team was really built
from the back forward although I love
what they did to their their defensive
line
um the Kansas City Chiefs I I you know
you just wonder
I'm starting to feel it already that
that they're everybody's gonna have the
same plan we got to take away Travis
Kelsey and now as the games get bigger
right he caught four touchdowns so it
sounds stupid but what do you have 30
yards in the game something like that
25. so but but at some point Come
Championship time and playoff time
somebody who's really not used to being
in that Spotlight is going to have to be
on the other end of it for Patrick and
you know it just it's just like this we
were just talking about with Jalen we
may at the end of this year go can you
believe we were even talking about could
Jalen hurts take this team over the top
and they went undefeated and destroyed
the Miami Dolphins record and but you
got to see it and I think that's the
same thing with Kansas City when when
you see those receivers make those big
plays in the big moments then yeah all
right they get it uh people want to meet
you they want to know what off-ramp
you're uh you're at right now are you at
a restaurant
you you know this neighborhood down here
I mean I'm just about to the Kenwood
mall there's a couple of phone calls
you've had uh you heard on there was my
wife who's going where the heck are you
I was going to attempt I was going to
attempt to do the show while driving no
no no no and I figured if you know if I
died on The Dan Patrick Show I would get
a lot of exposure it'd be great for you
it'd be less good for me but so I
decided to pull over I die on The Dan
Patrick Show every day at some point
Chris
um safe travels there hope you don't
trend on Sunday night
man me too brother me too thank you
Chris that's uh Chris Collinsworth
Sunday Night Football they will bring
you with Mike Tarico there uh Melissa
Stark on the sidelines it'll be the
Eagles and the Cowboys